the feds are investigating one of the
largest drug busts in U.S history
in June 2019 news breaks of a massive
seizure in the port of Philadelphia 20
tons of drugs and a single seizure
authorities say the drugs could have a
street value of more than one billion
dollars this was not like just any other
drug trafficking case yes drugs are
smuggled on container ships every day
but this one was extraordinary and this
one was different
it was not only the sheer quantity of
drugs it was also the level of
involvement of the crew
this wasn't just happening on one ship
the cartels penetration of msc's crewing
apparatus was so deep that they could
run multiple Crews on multiple ships
with these massive loads of drugs that
were going to Europe it really has
created this kind of Gangland feel that
overlays Global container ship in
that there's the world's largest
shipping company that's at the center of
this that makes it a very sensitive
topic and also one that could have
ramifications for The Wider shipping
industry
foreign
and problematic tension just in the
nature of the globalized economy most
people don't give a second thought to
the way that their goods arrive it all
arrives on these giant massive vessels
that are sailing around the world
ninety percent of global trade is
conducted on ships and every year 14
trillion dollars of goods are moved
around the world the shipping industry
is essentially the backbone of
globalization of a global economy what
that means is that there's this pressure
on ports and on shipping companies and
on Customs authorities to ensure that
global trade runs smoothly and that it
runs quickly every time a container is
opened that slows down the trade it also
prevents Security Services Customs
officials and others from
really digging in and examining the
containers as they move through this
system
reports of Northern Europe primarily
Antwerp in Belgium and Rotterdam in the
Netherlands have long been Central to
global trade dating all the way back to
the spice trade hundreds of years ago as
a result the infrastructure built up
around these ports has been increasingly
efficient and spectacular as the market
for cocaine has grown in Europe it only
makes sense to be shipping them through
these two ports in the North
that gives the traffickers an
opportunity to not necessarily service
the market in the Netherlands or in
Belgium but all across Europe and even
down into Africa and Asia as well we
visited one of these law enforcement
Customs stations where they scan cargo
that they believe contains illicit Goods
on this trip just a regular day in the
port of Antwerp Customs officials had
pulled aside a shipping container it had
a high risk level and they put it
through the scanner and ended up
searching it it was cocoa beans from
South America
upon searching the container they found
almost a thousand kilos of cocaine
we have several examples of where they
are
use all their creativity to
um to get things past us I'm going to
show you an image of a import of a
Cadillac a pink Cadillac and then you
see in the door of the Cadillac a kind
of strange packages
so when We examined it it was ecstasy 50
kilos of ecstasy as you see here they
filled like the shell of pineapples with
cocaine this one is an import of teak
from Ecuador the left pile of wood had
darker edges the cocaine was hidden in
the wood itself
and also the structure of the container
and the truck sometimes they hit stuff
in the structure like in the floor or
the ceiling on a yearly basis we are
talking about 40 to 50 000 containers
which are scanned the number of
containers entering and leaving the pork
are millions of millions and today we do
not have the infrastructure to scan all
the containers we scan 1.5 percent of
the containers entering the port of
Antwerp we stop a lot of tons but if you
look to the outcome the effect is zero
there is still huge quantities of
cocaine entering the European market
for Customs officials they're
essentially inundated with this problem
and really outmatched and that's
something actually that the traffickers
know and realize and have taken
advantage of
for them to lose a thousand kilos here a
thousand kilos there is not the end of
the world because they just expect that
they're just going to continue shipping
more
around 2008 2009 there was kind of a new
phenomenon that police officials Customs
authorities started noticing
these large commercial ships before they
entered the ports crew on board the ship
would actually toss over bags filled
with cocaine one of their collaborators
the co-conspirators would come up in a
smaller kind of fishing vessel and pick
up the cocaine and this was known as the
drop-off
and that was a really big breakthrough
what this meant was that there was
somebody on the ship
that was in on it
as European law enforcement
investigators started kind of honing in
on this problem of commercial shipping
companies being at the center of the
global cocaine trade they started
finding patterns putting together pieces
and they realized that there was one
shipping company that seemed to be at
the center of a lot of these drop-offs
and that was MSC
Mediterranean shipping company is known
by its initials MSC they are today the
world's largest Shipping Company MSC is
a really interesting company over a
period of five or six decades I think
from one ship to a fleet now of 650
surpassing everybody
it's a private company in Switzerland so
its finances in particular are pretty
opaque it does sort of make the miracle
that MSC is in terms of the Empire that
they built over a short period of time
all the more intriguing and all the more
mysterious
starting in the early 2000s MSC became a
major player in the sea Lanes from South
America to Europe they started investing
heavily in what are called reefers or
refrigerated containers to move
refrigerated Goods that turned out to be
a golden opportunity for the traffickers
because you basically could put the coke
inside containers of blueberries or
strawberries or bananas and it would
move quickly through the system and they
don't want to like slow those down
because the fruit is a perishable
commodity into Europe the cooling
compartment is a very popular place to
hide cocaine because that compartment
can be opened and closed without
breaking the seal of the container one
of the key moments in the build out of
this infrastructure was the expansion of
the Panama Canal in 2016. so you've got
much bigger ships much greater amounts
of cargo again much of a fruit and
vegetables Meats other kinds of
Commodities but that expansion around
2016 basically correlates with a big
jump in cocaine seizures in the ports of
Antwerp and Rotterdam
because MSC dominated this particular
route they became an easy target by
traffickers
law enforcement investigators started
seeing that cocaine that had made its
way to Europe
had actually stopped through a U.S port
so they started kind of working
backwards at first thinking if all of
this cocaine is ending up in Europe but
it's stopping in the U.S how did we not
detect it at the same time European
authorities are also conducting
investigations where they're coming
across the infiltration of other parts
of the shipping industry generally but
especially MSC so over the course of two
to three years
they started following
about four ships and that was the MSC
Desiree the MSC Carlotta the MSC Abney
and the MSC guyan
the MSC guyan is a monstrous ship this
is a ship that is the length of three
football fields it's one of the biggest
ships sailing the oceans today
MSU guyan was following a particular
route from the west coast of South
America through the Panama Canal up to
Philadelphia and from there from the
east coast of the United States over to
Rotterdam and Antwerp Diane set sail in
the spring of 2019 in mid-june after the
guyan had been at sea for many weeks it
pulled into the mouth of the Delaware
Bay this day instead of the guyan being
met by a Riverboat pilot they were met
by the Coast Guard Philadelphia police
Homeland Security officials Customs and
Border Protection officials there were
over a hundred law enforcement agents
waiting they Corral the crew start
questioning them swabbing their hands
for any traces of cocaine those came
back positive they started doing a
deeper inspection on the containers and
eventually found kind of their first hit
of cocaine and then they found more and
they found more and eventually came up
with the 20 tons initially law
enforcement investigators were stumped
how did they get so much cocaine on this
ship
so what they came to find out through
interviewing the crews and through other
kind of physical evidence that they were
able to obtain was that the cocaine was
actually loaded onto the ship while it
was in the open ocean of South America
as the Diane was powering through the
open ocean in the middle of the night
small boats pulled up alongside
and essentially loaded the cocaine that
way
the crew members used the crane of the
guyan
and basically hoisted up large Nets
filled with the bales of cocaine onto
the cargo ship
then they would take that cocaine and
then they pushed it into some of the
containers and basically stashed it on
the ship so it was an extremely Brazen
operation they do this loading at Sea
not just once but multiple times they
load it as it's going down the west
coast of South America turns around that
important Chile and then goes back up
and they do it several times on the way
back up there are eight crew members and
all on the Guyana that was involved in
the smuggling operation included the
chief mate and the chief mate as it
plays a really key role on the ship he
puts together the schedules for example
of a crewman so he can get the crew that
he knows are in on this operation
working for example all at night when he
needs them to be there to load the
cocaine he also has a lot of information
about the stowage plans so which
containers are going where
U.S authorities did not arrest the
captain of the ship but you don't need
the captain but for an operation like
this you do need a very senior officer
who can control the movement of the crew
the ships and all sorts of things and
keep in mind that this wasn't just
happening on one ship U.S authorities
had also made seizures on the Carlotta
and the Desiree which they believed
operate in exactly the same way this is
something that was by by 2019 June of
2019 it was pretty well oiled system so
that's why they were confident they can
move that that many drugs that tonnage
of cocaine on a single load in total
there were about eight crew members that
were implicated in the guyanes smuggling
and of those eight four of them had in
fact been recruited before ever stepping
foot on the guyan on that particular
Voyage at least one of them had been
recruited in their home country of
Montenegro
Montenegro has a long history of
seafarers the countries right on the
Adriatic produces a lot of sailors and
crewmen and officers who are very
skilled at what they do and they've been
playing the oceans for centuries
MSC Taps into that in in a way that's
bigger than any other shipping company
they employ basically a third or more
than a third of all Montenegro sailors
organize criminal groups are
particularly strong in the Balkans
there's a large network of individuals
and groups that have been operating
there for years really in the wake of
the breakup of Yugoslavia and the Balkan
Wars as the economy there collapsed it
beget a lot of crime
if you're a cartel if you're trafficking
drugs it only made sense and it was easy
for them to Target not only Sailors but
to Target Sailors on MSC ships
senior law enforcement officials from at
least three countries approached MSC
management and said look this is what
the problem is they had been told that
their crew were being recruited by the
Balkan cartel and so from the point of
view of law enforcement in Europe and
ultimately law enforcement in the U.S
MSC had multiple opportunities to try
and fix this problem before 2019 and
didn't do enough to do that
msc's view is that they did try and do
things that would help curb this problem
some cases they put guards on some ships
going from the east coast of South
America to Europe they tried to find
other ways which they could secure those
logistic lines from traffickers but
their point mainly is that we were doing
everything that every other shipping
company was doing
there's an ongoing investigation based
out of New York into the Balkan cartel
and key individuals in the cartel
recently there was a breakthrough arrest
in Miami this individual was a former
heavyweight boxer from the Balkans and
according to the indictment he played a
major coordinating role helping to
recruit Sailors aboard MSC ships there
are eight crewmen who were charged and
ultimately pled guilty in our in federal
prisons now
after the crew members were sentenced it
turned out the case wasn't entirely over
there was still the lingering question
of what responsibility does MSC have in
any of this and it turns out that
there's a statute that says essentially
that if you're caught with any illicit
Cargo in particular if you're caught
with cocaine you will be fined one
thousand dollars per ounce
Customs and Border Protection
authorities added up all the cocaine the
20 tons of cocaine multiplied it by the
one thousand dollars per kilo and came
up with what their fine would be it was
over 600 million dollars the largest
fine ever assessed against a commercial
carrier
the Diane was seized by U.S officials
during the course of the search and was
detained for over a month
the Guyana is worth at least 100 million
dollars but it's also once you seize it
you take one of these massive assets out
of the lineup of cargo ships that the
company is using to move Goods around
the world so it was a pretty shocking
event for MSC they reached an agreement
with U.S authorities to pay 50 million
dollars which is a sexually essentially
putting the ship out on bail there's a
civil case going on right now where
there's an effort by U.S authorities to
show that that initial seizure should
turn into a forfeiture in other words
MSC should lose the ship MSC is arguing
that they're not culpable US government
is arguing that in fact they are and
that case has the potential to really
change the map for shipping companies
us authorities really want to make an
example of this case for not just MSC
but the shipping industry generally
it's absolutely clear MSC wasn't itself
as a company smuggling the drugs the
Balkan cartel was smuggling the drugs
there's a question about how the company
behaves as its infrastructure is being
used and misused by drug trafficking
even the most amount of money that a
shipping company can spend on this on
guards and on cameras and on other
technology like smart containers that
can detect when a container is open even
throwing money at that it's going to be
very difficult to make a dent in this
problem because you still have an
enormous trade and cocaine even though
there were 20 tons of cocaine on that
ship it was just a fraction of the
overall cargo where the cocaine was
found in seven different containers but
that's seven containers out of four
thousand
it's a really really really hard problem
to solve
[Music]